during the interview process one of the
partners thought i was a little
dry
i didn't have a job the market was at a
very depressing low but
what i did have
was a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dami and i'm
a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver bc on this channel we talk
about architecture and design
and also some tools and strategies that
can help us have more meaningful and
fulfilling careers in architecture
having an online presence for me has had
a huge impact on my career
and so today i'm going to be talking
about the benefits of having an online
presence and your personal content when
you're applying for jobs how you can
define your niche what type of content
you should be focusing on and some of my
favorite features on wix who is kindly
sponsoring this video
so in march of 2020 i had finished all
my requirements to become a licensed
architect i had finished all my hours
and i passed all my exams
so i ended up leaving the firm that i
was at i had a small client on the side
um that was a franchise bakery and they
were expanding into different locations
it wasn't like super exciting work but
uh it was something that i could do
remotely while i took a break and kind
of tried to figure out my next move i
hadn't really planned on anything being
a basic avocado sitting millennial
i booked a yoga retreat in mexico
so i can chill and
open my chakras and
discover the meaning of life
and
that is when kovit hit
and shattered all my dreams kovit was
basically a death sentence for a lot of
retailers as you know
and so my client basically
scaled down their entire operation a lot
of their the projects got cancelled and
of course my yoga retreat
of course it got cancelled i was at a
point where
i didn't have a job
and the market was
at a very depressing low nobody was
hiring at that time but
what i did have
was a lot of time
and so that summer
that's when i started my youtube channel
and my official website a few months
into copid
i got a job offer from a company that i
was really interested in
and they had like a four-step interview
process and in the end what got me the
offer was my videos apparently during
the interview process one of the
partners thought i was a little
dry
um i don't know what that means but
maybe i was being too didactic maybe i
was nervous maybe i was trying to keep
it too like professional
um but after they had watched my videos
they kind of warmed up to me and
came through with an offer i think it's
almost like getting a second chance to
make a good impression
like it makes them feel like they know
you a little better you guys have
probably heard the statistic before but
like something like 70
of your interviewers are gonna google
you before they interview
and most firms these days they're
looking for people
um yeah to do the drawings and to do the
work but they're also looking for the
right fit
and for people who can make a meaningful
contribution to the firm when i went
into the interviews like almost everyone
knew about my videos which was
actually a little weird
but also cool because it gave them a
sense of like my interests and my
passions and what i'm into
um and it gives them a sense of like who
i am as a person before like ah me going
into trying to explain it to them of
course getting a job isn't the only
benefit of having an online presence it
can also help you establish yourself as
an expert in a topic
um on a personal level it can force you
to build expertise in a topic
it can help you make side income
it can help you make friends and meet
other people who have the same interests
and it can also get you raving fans
now i am not saying that you need to go
and make a youtube channel
in fact if you're in school you probably
want to use that time to focus on school
because this stuff is a lot of work
what i'm saying is like having some sort
of personal professional content online
that gives people a sense of who you are
and what your passions are
and like what you're knowledgeable in
can give you a competitive edge when
you're looking for a job
now architects by nature are generalists
so you could start a vlog and talk about
whatever your interests are from day to
day but we don't have an unlimited
amount of time in the day so you kind of
want this content to be as effective as
possible so if i were you um i would try
to develop a niche in one or two topics
i think that would be more beneficial
than doing something general but you
might be thinking uh but i don't really
have an expertise in anything
no problem
you can build expertise
that's literally what i did when i was
in my uh little slump
um i sat down and i asked these four
questions
uh what am i good at
uh what are my interests
what do i enjoy doing
what do other people say i'm good at and
do i have any proven accomplishments
you take the combination of that
and you don't have to
start off as an expert nobody is the
whole fun part is that through the
process of researching writing and
talking about it you are teaching
yourself
and slowly you are becoming someone
people can refer to the best part about
this creating educational content online
is not
the raging fans uh although i do really
appreciate you guys
it's not even the monetization
although i do love money
like forget about the jobs or the
monetization like it's really about me
and like helping me become a better
communicator
it is so true what they say like the
best way to learn something is to teach
it to other people
and when you can distill down ideas and
break it down in simple terms for other
people to understand
um and for other people to use
like you're learning so much more
through that process and i think that is
priceless
and that is something that not a lot of
courses can teach you
so one of the most effective ways to
build an online presence is having two
levels of content
long form this can be either a blog a
podcast um youtube channel
or articles on linkedin
and short form so this can be like
instagram twitter
by the way guys if you haven't added me
on these platforms go ahead and say hi
short form can help you get noticed and
long form will help you build authority
once you have the long form content it's
very easy to take that and sniff it up
and create short form content
uh i personally have not been too great
at doing this uh but i am trying to do
that right now
more instagram content coming up so in
my last video i gave you a step-by-step
tutorial on how you can put your work
online using wix who is kindly
sponsoring this video as well
if you haven't watched my other video on
how to create a website using wix go
ahead and watch that first
i'll link it
right here
i'll link it right here
so whether you're creating content on
youtube or on linkedin
you will definitely want to have your
own website or a home for all of that
content as well as for your personal
work your cv and your bio
so there's two i think effective ways to
create your content for your blog
um you can of course create multiple but
i think you can do it chronologically or
by category
i really really like wix because it's
very customizable and it's really
intuitive and very straightforward and
you can kind of lay things out visually
without having to learn to code or
anything one of the other things that i
really like is that you can embed a
video right into a blog post let's say
i wanted to
um
embed this
video
into the blog post i basically just do
this
and
voila
it's not a link it's a video directly
embedded into the post and this is great
for me because
i typically would put in my video into a
blog entry if i put out a new video that
specific week i also really like the
text editor it's pretty customizable you
can
change the boldness italics
it's like pretty standard stuff but you
can also change the color of the font
you can also change the highlight
you can also turn this into there's an
option for a quote
and of course if you want to undo this
you just reset to default
one way to keep all of your blog posts
organized is through categories and tags
so i've created a category um
personal
travel architecture and career
and so i can just select this category
and once i publish it
under that category
[Music]
so once i put it in that category i just
click into the category and then i'll
see my blog post
yeah the other thing that i really love
is that um let's say i had a series of
videos
in the thumbnail of the blog post you
can actually see a little preview of the
video
so let's say i populate this entire
page with posts of my videos i'll have
all of these moving thumbnails the
platform is very very customizable and
you can basically use it just like in
design so
you put an image in
and you can
customize it you can adjust it the way
you want right in the viewer
so i mean this is already an edited
image but if i just put in an unedited
image then
you can probably do like an auto enhance
and this part is actually really
cool you can change the brightness
bump up the contrast and highlights
and yeah i have played around with these
tools and they're actually quite nice
uh you can put in filters
like there's just so many different
options on um editing the image within
the wix platform
and this just cuts out a really big part
of the process because typically you
would have to go into photoshop or
illustrator or indesign and edit the
image or crop the image and then save it
as a jpeg and bring and then bring it
into your blog post but um in this case
you can edit it directly in the photo
studio here
and you can also add text
in directly into the images
that is a terrible font but uh
let's change that
let's say i want to put in captions
right directly on the image then i can
kind of do that directly in this editor
without having to go into indesign and
placing the text and exporting it as a
jpeg it just cuts out so much of the
work
and you can also
this is crazy you can also add a
freaking lens flare
how awesome is that
okay so i'm just gonna add the original
image so that you can see the comparison
okay
yeah this actually looks quite a lot
better
so yeah their photo editor is kind of
really great because it
basically cuts out the whole like
post-production
process
and
cuts out the need to use a whole
different set of programs so and they
have like presets and filters in there
that's kind of designed to make your
images look really good
so yeah that's pretty cool
and
once you gain um
a sizable following you can there's also
an option to monetize your blog post
i mean of course i would suggest
doing this once you have kind of a
sizable following
but yeah this is an option that's
directly embedded in their
toolbox
so yeah this is pretty cool so basically
it allows you to create um let's say you
have exclusive content
um it creates a paywall around that
content so that you can still have your
public content that you put out for free
but
for those special videos or special
articles you can put up a paywall so
that only people who have a membership
can access that content
so yeah
you can do a free plan
um like a one-time payment or you can
have an option to do a recurring payment
and yeah just like lots of ways to
customize the fee structure
and yeah i
really really enjoy using wix it's very
intuitive you can kind of lay things out
graphically without going into the back
end and learning how to use code and
i've used a lot of website builders in
my life i
had a vlog
since i was like 16 years old um so
that's more than 10 years i have not
found a platform that was as intuitive
and
[Music]
straightforward and just like very
visual so i think this is a great
platform for people who want a high
level of control but don't wanna
actually like
spend the time to actually learn how to
make a website
um and for people who are kind of like
picky about the way things look i really
like using it and um i think you guys
will like it too
if you guys found this video helpful hit
that like button and leave me a comment
um you know how much that helps with the
algorithm
if you want to check out my other videos
on the whole
job application process i have a video
on how to design your architectural
portfolio
i have one on how to put that portfolio
online
i also have some free templates um so
yeah check it out i'll leave it in the
end cards thanks a lot for watching guys
see you next time bye
[Applause]
[Music]